hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com so i hope you guys had a
good weekend it was the houston holidays
i personally spent this time with my
family and had some very relaxing time
so today is monday guys and the market
is open so i didn't have such a relaxing
time today on the market we have a
pretty bad day
so let's go through everything that
happened guys we're going to go through
amc jme press action i want to show you
some uh levels on triple q guys that are
very very important and that they're
going to be potentially a game changer
for what's going to happen this week in
the coming week i also have some good
things to show you guys on the oil
market and some other stocks related to
the all market so let's get into it
all right guys so as usual i'm gonna
start with amc the market is not closed
guys the market is closing in two three
hours but i'm doing my video right now i
hope this is good for you so uh amc
let's start on a daily timeframe first
bam bam bam so
in my last video i was telling you guys
that we have some good signs of reversal
i mean it's not a good sign of reversal
it's some early signs of reversal
because when a reversal is approaching
we often have different signs such as
bullish um divergence such as a
consolidation on low volume such as some
short-term breakout upset breakout so
here
i showed you guys on the on the hourly
timeframe so let me show you quickly
again we were having a bullish
divergence
bam it was here yes it's still here by
the way so this bullish divergence is
still impacting the press action and
it's just so very quickly bullish
divergence is whenever you have the
price action making new lows with the
momentum going higher all right just
like here the momentum is going higher
the price action is going lower so this
is showing you that bears are not able
to
take ground even on um
no sorry it's showing you this diversion
is showing you that uh the momentum is
is slowly starting to come back uh even
when the price action is making new lows
so we are in a bearish move because we
go lower but the momentum is coming back
so this is a
very early bullish sign uh to
to really have a bullish signal we need
to have this bullish divergence that is
combined with another signal related to
the press action such as a breakout so
this is what we were looking for guys
and here on the hourly time frame i
don't know if you see well i hope you do
um you can whenever you see a bullish
divergence you need to find a trend line
all right your trend line to um to place
it properly you need to have a lot of
reactions in the very recent past so
here as you can see guys we're having a
very nice consolidation all right so
this is showing me that this trend line
is active and that a lot of bears are
defending it so this trend line was very
good uh to have our bullish signal and
this morning at the open i was looking
at the market and i saw that we arrived
just on this trend line and what
happened here guys as you can see we got
brutally rejected so indeed bears were
here and they just rejected the price
action on
low volume i would say
so um
so what to
conclude from that we can just conclude
that we tried we didn't make it uh does
it mean that buzz are back in control
not really not really we still have the
momentum so bam
it's not nice we have here a breakout of
momentum you can see the macd is still
clearly going higher but the rsi is
making you lose so we have kind of kind
of you know mixed um
we have mixed signals on the short term
on amc
um
to me we are still in this consolidation
all right as you can see here if if i
check on the daily timeframe it's maybe
a little bit more visible just uh bam
bam bam sorry here
okay
you can see it's been like one two three
four it's the fifth day we are not
really uh going lower not going uh
higher
either we are slowly uh a little bit
grounding lower so bears are a little
bit in control still but booze are
definitely trying something but for now
they are not strong enough uh the reason
being uh that the rest of the market is
tanking guys alright so uh this is the
reason why booze have uh some troubles
here to take back control so what can we
expect here to be honest um
it's hard to say probably a little bit
more consolidation
uh the worst case scenario i see right
now is to go to the 16 level then
rebound once again the first time it's
almost always
it's it's something that always almost
uh almost always happens sorry uh
whenever a support has not been touched
for quite some time if it's if it's
touched uh for the first time in a while
then usually we have a bullish reaction
then what's gonna happen i don't know
but if we go there we're gonna have this
bullish reaction the best thing uh to be
honest is to consolidate as close as
possible to this trend line so right now
amc's
is trying to fight back we're down four
percent so it's not that bad uh the rest
of the market is
is starting to be positive i'm going to
analyze that as well so here what are we
looking for either we go to 16 i'm gonna
be a buyer here at 16. it's fine my
position starts to be big but i can
still increase it
um i'm not 100 yet i'm gonna buy lower
i'm gonna buy higher whenever i have
some bullish signals here the bullish
signal i'm looking for is once again
once again a breakout above this trend
line uh now it's not going to be as good
as if if it has happened today because
today we're looking perfectly nice guys
we were having this consideration and
the breakout is very reliable whenever
it happens just after a consolidation on
low volume very close to the resistance
area so this was a perfect situation we
just didn't have the breakout so let's
see the perfect thing would be to do
that again conciliate again here and
then bam have a breakout with volume
increase all right guys this is what
we're looking for if i say that i'm
gonna be a buyer
um
oh right and guys you know my um
longer term
analysis i can do it quickly again guys
uh i was expecting a third wave to er to
happen here uh it's still possible but
once again the probability of this
massive third wave to the 70 area even
slightly above has reduced a lot after
we broke out below 21 all right which
was the 61.8 fib ratio which is a level
which we usually don't go in second wave
so whenever the price action is going
below that level it can still bounce of
course and i think that we're gonna have
a technical bounce coming uh sooner or
later but right now this third wave
scenario i still keep it here guys
because it can still happen but just the
probability is lower so we're gonna need
to see what happens once we come back to
this area so this is what i am playing
right now this is what i'm targeting um
and let's see what
what's gonna happen whenever we arrive
there if we arrive with increasing
volume just like we did here it's gonna
be looking very good if we arrive in
this area on low volume guys
that won't be looking good but for now
we are not there yet bears are still in
control we are trying to take back
control uh but we need this breakout
above the 18 level is it let me show you
guys that again bam bam bam right now
it's around 18 okay let's say tomorrow
okay around 18 guys if tomorrow we close
above 18 on the hourly time frame
i mean on the hourly timeframe is not
good enough we need at least four hours
all right
at least um four hourly candles or one
for our scandal to be uh closing above
that eighteen level so let's find out
guys let's see what's gonna happen here
gme jme guys uh was strong so let me
show you what i was um talking about in
my last video uh so very quickly daily
time frame uh here the situation is that
we are looking much better than amc
because we are much higher in terms of
retracement of the second wave as you
guys can see even if today we are coming
to the 50
um level
that has been touched by the way and we
had here a bullish reaction um i mean
the rsi is still above 50 50.5 so not
that far above the macd has to negative
already last week so we have mixed
signals coming from the momentum but uh
fibs are giving us quite good
information because we are still above
this 50
uh fib ratio which is the neutral area i
would say uh we can go lower we can go
to 120 we we would still be bullish on
the long term here
um so now on the hourly timeframe guys i
was showing you in my last video
uh i lost a little bit of money here by
the way um i was showing you guys that
this 150 2.3 level was very important we
had here because it has been a level
that has been touched many times in the
past uh week here as you can see let me
get rid of the film so you see better
bam okay
so here as you can see we had this
consolidation let me do that again
all right just here and uh whenever we
have a consolidation this is a good
environment for breakouts so then we
need to find a good resistance and we
need to find a breakout with increase in
volume here as you can see we had this
breakout
i'm not sure uh
when i did the video if the scandal was
finished or not but here clearly we can
see that the volume was not here i
personally still jumped uh in the trade
here because i don't want to miss it and
i formed a little bit uh i lost money
but it's a cool option so it's totally
fine
um
i mean i'm not scared for strong moves
down because anyway my code will expire
worthless so this is the good thing
about cool options
is that at least you know the maximum
loss you can make so this is the reason
why i personally prefer to go to options
for now i also have shares of course
but here i i did this try it didn't work
so what happened here you can see we
have this breakout so this hourly candle
is closing above the 152.3
level but the volume increase was not
here then we had like one two
two candle
above
then below then above and we we played
around this level but we didn't manage
to uh take back control here and this is
the reason why i told you guys better to
go on the fourth time frame because on
the first time frame we have one close
above but the next one is below so once
again depending on how reactive you want
to be uh you're gonna sometimes use the
hourly sometimes the four hours time
frame you're gonna sometimes wait for a
second candle sometimes not so there is
no magic formula it's about uh as well
the other signals in this case i
personally want it to be reactive and i
went in too early
then we got here as you can see brutally
rejected and this is often what happens
and once again i'm explaining that very
well guys in the uh in my course you can
find it by clicking on the in the link
on description of this video am i i'm
explaining everything guys that i'm
showing you here and here for example uh
this is what you call a stop hand so
this is a good example so whenever you
have a breakout on low volume uh that is
not working then usually you have a i
mean a fake out then then usually you
have a breakout which is a real breakout
in the opposite directions here it's a
little bit what we had here we didn't
manage to um to close and stay above
this 152 level and then here we have
this breakout that is not looking good
um right now clearly on the short term
bears and control um
i'm checking the momentum the momentum
is flatter so no big information
um it's hard to say what's going to
happen here we have a little bit the
same phenomenon that is happening now
around the 142 level as you guys can see
this level has been
uh acting
has been acting as support very well one
two three four five five reactions and
here it has been broken and now we are
we are somehow coming back to test it
um i'm not sure what's gonna happen you
know it has not been respected here so
maybe it's not gonna be respected here
uh we have a lot of noise the signals
are not very good quality because there
is no volume as you can see we have here
a brutal move down on very low volume so
whenever you have low volume does it
mean that the signal will not work no it
just means that it's less reliable so we
had here a fake out on the upside uh
maybe it's a fake cap on the doubt side
i don't know um
but
to me we're still in this consolidation
that is still you know taking place a
little bit like on amc as long as we
don't have a second candle below this
142 level uh to me we are still you know
in this range between 142 and 152 like
we have been for the past week if 142
breaks on the daily timeframe so if we
get a close today below this level
um
this will go together with the rest of
the market but we
we are likely to go test the next
support which is 130. so the 130th gme
will probably go together with the 16 of
mc so hopefully we won't need to go
there to find more liquidity more buyers
waiting there because once again the
only good thing about going lower is
that we get new buyers in the move which
is of course good the more buyers the
more money the better it is to um to
make strong moves up so sometimes
pulling back is a good thing
um so let me conclude here i mean we
have a lot of noise whenever you have
noise you know it is a corrective move
so here the good thing i have is that i
have a noisy move down so bears are not
organized the move up was it noisy guys
was it
i mean
do you think this move up was a clean
move up that is respecting all the usual
rules and i can tell you it is guys it
is we are the one two three four five
with a massive volume inside the third
wave fib ratios were respected i mean
this was a very very clean move up
with a one-to-one relation uh that
happened here so then this move down is
corrective so can it go lower yes it can
but it's just showing us that whenever
we go up we are organized whenever we
move down it's not organized it's noisy
you know you have a lot of fake outs so
this is rather confirming to me that
bulls and control on the long term so i
like to see bursts disorganized on the
downside
uh now something else i want you to show
you guys triple q because once again
this is all related i told you guys many
times we often have the negative beta
taking place before strong moves up on
amc or gme negative beta means negative
correlation means the global market is
tanking when the uh meme stock mcgme are
uh mooning and
i'm i like to see this negative beta at
play um so today we have it right now
but i prefer to see it in uh in the
other direction of course the global
market is slightly positive right now
gme and amc are uh going lower but what
is important in that in this analysis is
that you don't want to have a global
market that is tanking if you want meme
stocks to squeeze
for proper squeeze to happen it's going
to take a few weeks we need to have a
bull market so here um i'm following
this trade for quite some time
um
i will not explain again everything that
i'm doing here guys but basically i took
a bearish position here at 370 yes close
to the highs guys it's much easier to do
technical analysis on triple tune this
is where i personally make my money uh
when i made most of my money the past
two three months
um so i'm gonna keep trade of course
this uh etf which is the nasdaq hundred
etf uh here i took profit uh at 350
and then i took a long position at
338 so i'm planning i'm playing this
third wave here that could happen and go
to this area it's not my preferred
scenario my preferred scenario is some
sideways movement and then a direction
that will be taken maybe on the upside
maybe maybe on the damn side i'm not so
bullish guys on the global market we are
still in a complicated situation with
the inflation uh with the war with the
growth that is impacted with the covet i
mean um we have paul that is going to
talk i think on wednesday or thursday
this week so let's see what he says but
we are not in a nice situation so i
personally don't know where the market
will go i'm rather neutral at this
levels um
and i'm playing you know supports and
resistances i'm buying low and selling
high whenever the market is bullish i
buy high and sell higher i'm buying
breakouts on the upside whenever the
market is moving sideways like that i
just buy the dip and sell the rip so
this is what i'm gonna try to do here
again uh so today as you can see guys in
my discord by the way feel free to join
and you have a six months membership
platinum membership that is offered guys
in the course as well so if you really
interested to learn how to trade join
the discord join the course i mean just
take the course come to chat with me on
discord i will upgrade you to platinum
and you can have a six month free
membership uh on discord if you don't
want to have the course because you
think that you are good enough which is
totally fine you can still ask your
questions to me in this code every day i
will share my trades with you uh and
maybe one day you will take the course
if you need you can have a discount once
your platinum you can have a discount as
well so there are many ways to have the
course at a good price and the
membership at a good price as well so
today my trades were uh quite simple so
yeah i'm gonna show you you uso as well
we're making some good money here uh but
triple q first uh just the usual one i
buy three three eight and i stop plus
three three five so this is what i did
today so i'm making some money here um i
bought at 338 and you can see we had
some sort of a fake out as well here on
the downside
but it's not a fake out as long as you
don't have a close below three three
eight so this is what i was saying today
in my discord i was telling you guys
that we're gonna open lower you can see
guys this is what i said we are about to
up and lower so i said that this morning
uh before market open we are about to
open below 338 which is not great but
totally fine as long as we do not close
below that level today all right this is
this is what i said this morning and i
said if we do three three eight will be
resistance blah blah blah for now we
keep our thursday order we buy three
three eight we stop loss uh three three
five so today the market went to 335.8
i have not been stopped and i'm happy to
be in this position i'm now having a
long position on triple two i'm gonna
try to take profit around 350. the
interesting thing of the day guys is the
rally that we're having that is
confirming uh that is i mean confirmed
not confirmed yet but it's that is
looking much better than uh yesterday
and the day before uh on the oil market
guys why because um
[Music]
we have french
presidential election coming in four
days guys or six days sorry and
um
[Music]
and there is a ban of the oil of the
russian oil that is gonna take place i
think
uh an embargo
on um that is coordinated by the us by
europe that are waiting for the french
presidential election to pass so next
week and then they're gonna probably
pass that depending who is elected
macron or marine le pen who is a little
bit close to russia not really close but
you know they will for sure uh
not vote for this um ban of russia oil
so my take is that macron is gonna pass
because this is france guys and we're
not gonna have uh
you know um
this kind of president i mean marine le
pen who is a bit
uh i would say not very pro-europe not
very pro
um
economy but whatever so i think that
macro is gonna pass and i think that
then they're gonna pass this low so this
law should happen maybe during the
weekend or just after i'm not sure and
this law is gonna be uh adding a strong
market mover on oil so i think that this
is what's gonna happen so here
uh i want to buy more i'm having already
a very nice position here making some
good money here on the street today this
trade that i gave you guys once again in
my discord i'm not going to show you
again but i gave you this trade and
right now we're starting to take profit
so this morning we took uh 50 of the
profit at 80.5
we entered here guys at the low yes and
um and i think that we're going to go
205 on uso which is equivalent on oil
around 140. all right so i'm predicting
here a massive move up on the oil market
uh and i'm gonna show you something very
cool guys in uh in in two minutes
i'm just concluding here
right now i'm gonna try to use fibs to
buy more so whenever you use fib you
just measure the move and you use fibs
to enter if you don't know what ratio
you should use then take my course
because i'm explaining all of that but i
can give you some hint you need to
combine that with the other support
levels all right so here uh i placed a
buying order
around 100 uh if you want to know more
once again join the discord guys i'm not
sure we're going to see it again but if
we do this would be a typical second
wave pullback and then we'll probably
move higher developing in five waves as
we usually do only on amc ngme things do
not happen as usual but fair enough
right it's it's a different market with
different players there is manipulation
we know that so
i mean we need to adapt uh but
to me the best way to adapt is not to
change anything and each time i'm going
to see a bullish sign
and a bullish situation for a squeeze to
happen i will be a buyer and i will uh
post videos very bullish about amc and
gme
because
even if there is manipulation at some
point guys they can't manipulate the
market forever so let's see what's gonna
happen to come back on the old market
guys this market is very strong here
actually look the volume are not that
big so this is to me a little thing that
is
i mean not perfect
everything here looks perfect look guys
it's it's um it's a long-term view i'm
having i'm sharing this analysis for the
past two three months guys i've been
very accurate here because once again
it's like a civilized market you know
things are more predictable i would say
than on some other markets
and here we had a long-term breakout
above the bluetooth land that was here
and after this kind of breakout let me
get rid of that
we often have a pullback as we did let's
check quickly to which fib ratio
around the 50 percent classic pullback
and then we had a triangle forming and
now we have a breakout above this
triangle upper bend the only thing is
that here as you can see during this
breakout we had the volume uh during
this breakout we we have a lower volume
so that's not good guys that's not good
but my longer term analysis is solid
enough for me to enter this kind of
bracket once again you will never have a
perfect
sign signal in i mean sometimes it
happens you have some signals that are
almost perfect but most of them they're
not perfect you need to choose which one
you're going to enter um even if it's
not perfect and this one i decided to
enter because i have some longer term uh
signals that are very good and that it
makes total sense when i look at the
fundamentals at the re at what is
happening in the world the war my take
on the war of course i have no clue
what's gonna happen i'm not an expert of
war but um my take is that it's gonna
last because i mean this is what most
experts are saying and i think it makes
sense i think that putin will not let it
go without having some serious uh comp
compensations and i think that um
zelinski will not uh give those
compensations so easily so it will take
time and if it takes time of course it
is bullish for the for the oil market
which is of course very sad uh i don't
wish it take time but it's just the
analysis i'm making
uh all right so uh the
the play i want to share with you guys i
didn't post an alert in my discord with
that this was given to me by a member
scott if you watch this video thank you
brother
um
because i think it's interesting and i
want to share it with you guys here on
youtube once again i didn't share it in
this code because this play is not
perfect but as you guys can see this is
cei camber energy it's um oil related
company
and um they are ranging between one and
four for the past
one or two years all right two years
um and right now as you can see you know
we can make something here but basically
things often happen the same way all
right you have some kind of trendline
then a breakout then we we go to four
then we move lower then you know again
and just pass so right now it looks like
uh we are in a move up that started here
as you can see breakout with increase in
volume clearly here here increasing
volume as well
a bit noisy though but it's still a
breakout with increasing volume after a
nice consolidation
and i think that this is just a longer
move so it looks like we're going to
four but i mean we don't have any clear
signals on the short term the only thing
that is good here is the signals i'm
having on the oil market
because this is an oil related stock and
the reddit crowd is uh going at it uh
probably because it's related to what is
happening on the oil market
with the old market so i think that the
oil is gonna keep going higher so we
have here uh i mean high probability
that this move continues higher
and in terms of risk reward i mean this
is kind of capped
sorry i said one it's 0.5 i mean this
cannot go below zero right so the worst
case scenario is that you lose one and
the best case scenario you make three so
to three to one risk reward trade so i
think that it's a nice trade to make
but once again i don't share it on my
discord because i don't have a nice
consolidation
that happened before this breakout i'm
monitoring this breakout we have here
clearly a resistance at 1.04
but
we are testing it uh on with some volume
increase so this is a nice situation i
could actually post it i don't post it
because i'm missing here some kind of
consolidation all right and whenever you
have some consideration just below the
resistance it makes your signal more
reliable and i'm trying to share those
signals with
my community
so uh bambam or i'm gonna share some by
the deep seldo rip trades that are
easier to make once again when you are
in a sideways market so
last but not least guys silver also
going well this is a trade i did with
you guys when i was live this is a trade
i shared with my discord as well uh i
think we started the fifth wave i think
we're just going to go to 26 in a matter
of a few weeks
so i'm personally positioned to make
money if this scenario happens so that's
it for today i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to click on the sub like and bell
button so you're going to be the first
to know when i upload anything new and
stay close to show i'll see you guys